欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一下关于精细化产品线的布局
通过直通车快速拉升整个店铺的流量
第一个原则就是我们要想办法单点突破
找到一个品类切入
在有限的直通车预算下
快速拉升全店的流量
锁定精准优质的买家
我们很多人在用直通车推广的时候
都喜欢推广很多很多的产品
或者是说
他店铺里面有几十个品类
各种品类在混合推广
各种品类交叉推广
这种情况都会导致你直通车造成大量的预算浪费
而且很多品类都是没有办法做起来的
所以说
他的店铺就会非常的乱
而且效果非常的差
那么通过这节课的学习
我们来教大家怎么样去
选品类去推广
怎么样去从单点突破整个店铺的流量
第一个就是品类的选择上面
我们一定要均从下面三个条件去选择品类
第一个一定要选择公司有优势的产品
而且是容易成交的
你可能是贸易公司有过往的历史记录
可以知道哪些产品是公司更有优势的
或者是供应量是更有优势的
那么这些是优先考虑的产品
第二个就是
这些产品的关键值指数高不高
流量稳不稳定
关键值总量多不多
因为这些关键值指数高
流量稳定关键值多
都决定着你整个市场的需求
跟市场的容量的大小
决定着你获取流量的难易程度
所以说这里也是一个值得考虑的
这些越高流量越稳定
关键值越多的就可以优先考虑
那么第三个就是符合当项市场
迫切需求的产品更容易发送商机
比如说你去做一些季节性的产品
夏季流量大
冬季流量少
那么这个时候你就要慎重的去选择
你当前这个阶段所要做的产品
你要去做当前这个市场上
比较有迫切需求的
不然的话
你的产品可能会有很多点击
但是没有那么容易获得商机
因为这些时段
客户并不是迫切需求的
他可能是正在逛这些市场上的各个商家的产品
去选好
提前选品
但是并不急着去下班
所以说你想要交易或者是想要获取商机
就一定要去做当前市场上
更加迫切需求的产品
那么具体的方法怎么样去做呢
第一个就是去
直通车推广
一到三个品类
比如说你整个店铺有10到20个品类
但是呢你的预算是非常有限的
可能是500块钱
那么你就要从这10到20个品类里面去选一到三
或者是一到五个品类去进行推广
通过这一到五个品类或一到三个品类去提升你整个店铺的总流量
通过这些品类的流量提升来提升你这个店铺的权重
来让其他品类的产品的关键词有更高的权重获取更多的流量
这是反过来作用于店铺里面的其他品类
第二个呢就是你推广的这些品类有了商机之后
如果它的访客点击的关键词都是非常精准的
那么这种产品你要及时的补充订单绑定订单
让这些产品快速的打爆
只有这些产品成为爆品了
那么你的流量才会出现单点突破
同时呢也会让你的直通车推广的成本下降
所以一定要注意这个环节非常的重要
第三个呢就是一定要去绑定多点产品
让更多的产品成为实力优品或者是优品
爆品这些都非常关键
一定要多利用现有的资源就可以了
那么这一节课就是在讲
我们怎么样去选择店铺里面的一些产品进行推广
来快速拉升整个店铺的流量
希望这些思路你能够按照这样的方法去操作去执行
因为很多人他都是很迷茫的
不知道选什么类型的产品去推广
也不知道推广哪些品类
店铺品类又多预算又少
不知道怎么样去做
那么你就可以参考这个方法去执行起来
你的店铺一定能够很快的建设
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见